Je reviendrai ce qu'il en est,
mais j'ai trois des mots les plus emblématiques que vous connaissiez
dans l'histoire du cinéma Je
t'attendais Je ne peux pas te faire Tom
une activité qui t'honore
non  c'est la première chose qui vous
vient à l'esprit quand vous pensez à
tous les films
qu'Arnold a créé ce personnage en 1980
et c'est l'un des
personnages et films les plus emblématiques des 50 dernières
années
agréable de vous voir il entre dans une pièce et
il  apporte juste une présence et un charisme
avec lui qui sont indéniables
bonjour les calories c'est agréable de vous rencontrer
tu te moques de moi
Thomas a été génial il est très amusant à
avoir et super généreux et juste
un grand membre de l'ensemble je ne pourrais pas l'
imaginer sans  lui et c'est drôle
, j'essaierais de penser à quels autres
films je ressentirais ça et il
n'y en a pas beaucoup et nous avons comme Mikey
sûr qu'il garde tout le reste en ligne
parce qu'il le cloue à chaque fois qu'il
a ce personnage donc  vers le bas c'est le
rôle emblématique
qu'il aime w  ce qu'il fait et donc l'énergie
qu'il apporte à cela est fantastique il est
plus grand que nature mais pourtant vos copains
gagnent un plaisir que ce soit dans la
chaise de maquillage ou que vous soyez sur le plateau ou
que vous sachiez que vous rentrez
chez vous avec Arnold  c'est un homme bon et il est
ramené à la maison avec